what is the difference between a woman
playing hard to get and not being
interested
the person the guy who she's talking to
the guy who she's talking to do you feel
like women make it clear if they're
interested or not interested nah cause
some women like
the idea of someone being interested in
them but like no
interest in the person so like they
might like string it along so like
sometimes it's really unclear like they
like the attention
yeah yeah definitely
do you feel like um women flirt because
they like the attention 100
100. but they have no actual interest in
the guy yeah obviously like situational
but like yeah there's times where like
girls will be flirting and they've got
no interest in anything except like they
like how it makes them feel do you think
that makes it confusing for men
yeah obviously like it's a bit like you
know it's definitely confusing like some
guys would be like i don't even know
what i'm doing here like yeah we're on
it we're not on it so yeah do you feel
like women actually know what they want